So, let's talk about the War on Drugs.
Today we're going to dig into the playbook behind it, using some pretty revealing documents
and interviews to see how this one political strategy really changed the course of a nation's
history.
Let's kick things off with a quote, a really stunning admission from deep inside the Nixon
White House.
This one line pretty much reframes the entire story of the War on Drugs.
So you gotta ask, right?
Who said this?
And what in the world were they lying about?
Okay, so let's dive into this.
The crazy thing is, this quote came out way back in a 1994 interview, but it just kind
of sat there.
It flew completely under the radar for more than 20 years until, boom, a 2016 article
in Harper's Magazine brought it to light and it just exploded.
And we're not talking about some low-level staffer here, nope.
The person who said this was John Ehrlichman.
He was one of President Nixon's most trusted advisors, a key architect of domestic policy.
So when he talks, you listen.
And his confession, wow.
It gives us this really chilling peek into the cold, hard political math that was going
on behind the scenes.
The journalist who did the interview said Ehrlichman was just brutally honest.
He basically laid it all out.
The Nixon campaign, he said, had two enemies, the anti-war left and black people.
And while you can't just make it illegal to be against a war or to be black, so they
had to get creative.
They needed another way to go after those communities to disrupt and dismantle them.
And this is the playbook he described.
It's pretty methodical.
Step one, you create a public association.
You link the hippies with marijuana and you link black people with heroin.
Step two, you make both those things super illegal, criminalize them heavily.
And once you've done that, you've got the perfect excuse to disrupt their communities,
right?
You can raid their homes, arrest their leaders, and, in his own words, vilify them night
after night on the evening news.
It was a political weapon.
He admitted it.
So this whole strategy, targeting specific groups of people without actually naming
them, this wasn't just a one-time thing.
Oh no, it actually became the foundation for a whole new kind of political language.
You could call it an abstract attack, one that was specifically designed to hide what
it was really about.
And that brings us to this.
Well, it's a pretty infamous interview from 1981 with a guy named Lee Atwater, who was
a top Republican strategist.
But he just spelled it out.
He explained exactly how political messaging had to change once you couldn't use overtly
racist language anymore because it would backfire.
The solution?
Coded phrases.
Atwater literally described it as a three-step evolution.
You start out using explicit slurs.
Then, when that stops being socially acceptable, you pivot.
You switch to coded phrases, like states' rights.
And then, the final step, you move to something that sounds totally neutral, like abstract
economic policies, things like cutting taxes.
But as Atwater himself pointed out, a byproduct of those policies is that blacks get hurt
worse than whites.
So the language gets cleaner, more abstract, but the intended effect?
That stays the same.
You've probably heard the name for this tactic.
It's called a dog whistle.
You know, like a whistle-only dogs can hear?
It's a political message that sounds totally innocent to the general population, but for
a specific, targeted audience, the real meaning comes through loud and clear.
So in this context, something like states' rights wasn't just about states' rights.
It became a dog whistle for pushing back against federal civil rights enforcement.
Now as shocking as all this is, the Nixon administration didn't just invent this playbook
out of thin air.
Not at all.
There was a clear historical precedent for this.
It goes back decades.
So let's rewind.
Let me introduce you to a man named Harry Anslinger.
This guy was basically the nation's first drug czar, way back in the 1930s.
And he led America's first big war on drugs, and his target was almost entirely marijuana.
And Anslinger's campaign, well, it was fueled by some just blatantly racist rhetoric.
He really didn't even try to hide his motivations.
He was constantly and directly linking drug use to what he saw as a threat to the existing
racial hierarchy.
I mean, his official justifications were this toxic cocktail of racial and cultural fear.
He just relentlessly tied marijuana to minority groups, and also to cultural things he didn't
like, like jazz and swing music.
The whole campaign was framed as this urgent threat to white society.
Okay, so we've seen the playbook.
We've seen the language.
But what were the real world consequences?
What actually happened because of this strategy from Anslinger all the way up through Nixon
and beyond?
Well, the data, it paints a pretty devastating picture.
Just look at this timeline.
It's undeniable.
The moment President Nixon officially declared a war on drugs back in 1971, the U.S. prison
population just starts to skyrocket.
It's a climb unlike anything else in modern history.
We're talking from around 300,000 people back then to well over 2 million today.
And what was driving this explosion in the prison population?
Overwhelmingly, it was one thing.
Drug offenses.
The number of people in prison or jail for a drug crime went up by an incredible 1,100
percent after the war on drugs really ramped up in the 1980s.
Just think about that number for a second.
And as you can probably guess, this massive increase was not felt equally across the board.
Not even close.
Black Americans make up about 13 percent of the U.S. population.
But if you look at the historical data, they've accounted for nearly 60 percent of the people
in state prisons for drug offenses.
So what explains that?
How is that massive disparity even possible?
Well here's the thing.
Decades of research have looked into this.
And it's not because of different rates of drug use.
The data is crystal clear on this.
White and black Americans use and sell illicit drugs at almost identical rates.
The difference, the real difference, is in enforcement.
It's about who gets stopped, who gets searched, and ultimately, who gets arrested.
So all of this brings us full circle, right back to the legacy of this political playbook
and the kind of language that it created.
The pattern becomes pretty clear when you lay it all out like this.
When one form of direct discrimination becomes socially unacceptable, new, more abstract
language is created to justify policies that, well, they produce a very similar result.
In this case, the phrase, tough on crime, effectively stepped in to do the political
work that tough on segregation just couldn't do anymore.
You know, understanding this history isn't just about memorizing facts and dates.
It's really about learning to see the systems that are at play behind the headlines, behind
the political rhetoric.
There's actually a term for this.
Some sociologists call it developing a critical consciousness.
As one scholar put it so well, the language just shifted.
Arguments about black criminality simply replaced the older arguments about black inferiority.
It allowed for a similar outcome, but it was all done under this much more socially acceptable
banner of just being tough on crime.
And that really leaves us with a final thought to chew on.
This playbook, this idea of using coded, abstract language to target a specific group, it doesn't
just live in history books.
It's a powerful and really persistent political tool.
So the real question for all of us is, now that you know the playbook, where do you see
it being used today?